-We maybe have done ourselves
a disservice
of adapting to how outrageous
and shocking the news is
every day,
that we´ve lost our capacity
to be shocked by it.
-You know, the incredible
superpower of human beings
is that they can
make things normal.
Their adaptability, right?
So, what´s the species
that can live
in the Amazon and the Arctic?
-Right.
-Right? And the reason is,
we´re very good
at just being, like,
"Well, it´s cold all the time.
We´re gonna build an igloo, and
we´re gonna hunt some whales,
and we´re gonna get through."
And so because that is
the human-being superpower --
That is the essence
in some ways of being a human.
You adjust and acclimate
to whatever situation
you find yourself in.
And so the president
goes on Twitter and says,
"I am, in front of all of you,
officially instructing
my attorney general
to open an investigation
of my chief political rival."
Like, no, you can´t do that.
-Right.
-If you did that in secret
and we found out about it,
that might be impeachable.
If Barack Obama did that, it
would probably be impeachable.
But because
we´re sort of acclimated --
Like, "Oh, he´s tweeting again."
-Yeah.
-Like, he --
It is amazing in some ways
what we are able
to acclimate to.
-Well, the other thing
that´s amazing is it seems like
it´s not just people who are
critical of the president
and sort of
on the opposing side,
it seems like people within
the president´s inner circle
also say,
"Hey, you can´t listen
to what he says
or writes or does.
Like, that´s -- that´s not fair
to take him at his word."
He´s full of [bleep].
Like, don´t you think
that´s what they´re saying?
-Yes! In fact --
And I actually think my --
One of my theories about the man
is that in some weird way,
I think we think of him
as avaricious
and ambitious
and he wants to be powerful.
I think it´s the opposite.
I think what he actually wants
is the trappings of the office,
but he mostly wants to be a guy
live-tweeting "Fox & Friends."
I don´t think he actually --
In a weird way, I don´t think
he wants the responsibility.
Like, he wants to be
the guy at the bar
that everyone has to listen to.
-Yeah.
-And I think he likes
living in the Oval Office.
But when it´s like, "Hey, sir,
we´ve got a tough decision
to make here about what
we´re doing in North Korea."
It´s like, "I´d rather
live-tweet ´Fox & Friends.´"
You know what I mean?
So it´s like --
Not only do his defenders say,
"Well, that´s just him talking,"
in an own way,
like, he doesn´t seem to care
about what actually happens
in the world.
What he cares about is that
the attention is on him.
-So you think if we just let
him, like, take the Oval Office
and, like, remove it and, like,
roll it to New York...
-"Truman Show" it.
-And he could just do a podcast.
-Oh. If you gave --
If you gave Donald Trump a
podcast, he would be so happy.
-Yeah.
-And the world would be
such a better place.
-I would love it. I would listen
to a Donald Trump podcast.
-Give him a podcast!
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, all right.
Well, I guess we just pitch it
to him and see what happens.
-"Sir, we need about
30 minutes of your time.
We´ll be right in and out."
-Thanks so much for being here.
It´s always a pleasure.
Have a great show tonight.
Chris Hayes, everybody!